bonjour à tous bienvenue pour notre
traditionnel point presse
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir bruno
beschizza qui est notre secrétaire
national en charge de la sécurité qui
viendra qui reviendra sur la
consultation des adhérents par rapport
aux propositions qui ont été faites
suite à notre journée de travail sur la
sécurité
mais tout d'abord je commence par notre
traditionnel agenda prévisionnel donc à
19 heures ce soir aura lieu une grande
réunion publique régionale de soutien à
bruno retailleau qui est donc peut-être
de liste des républicains pour la région
pays de loire en présence de nicolas
sarkozy et de jean christophe lagarde
cette réunion aura lieu à la salle
jeanne de laval 29 grand'rue à andard
mardi 10 novembre
11h15 nicolas sarkozy participera à la
réunion du groupe des républicains à
l'assemblée nationale et dans cette
journée du 10 novembre il y aura un
déplacement de travail en allemagne dans
le cadre de l'élaboration du projet des
républicains en lien avec la cd eu
c'était les groupes de travail qui avait
été annoncé en janvier dernier avec
angela merkel donc ils auront à cette
journée de travail luc chatel eric
woerth pierre lequiller et catherine
troendle qui est président du groupe
d'amitié franco allemands ozil et donc
samedi 14 novembre aura lieu à 10h30 la
réunion des nouveaux adhérents
donc cette réunion ait lieu ici
et à cette occasion nous communiquerons
les chiffres des adhérents des
républicains et ces chiffres seront
fait par constat d'huissier de manière à
ce qu'ils soient incontestables et nous
invitons le parti socialiste à faire de
même à faire appel le plus souvent
possible aux huissiers pour que là aussi
les chiffres qui soient annoncées ne
soient pas fantaisistes on l'a vu à
l'occasion de leur grand référendum où
finalement tout s'est fait un petit peu
à la va vite et donc le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que les chiffres
étaient soumis à caution
en ce qui concerne les prochaines
semaines dit si des élections régionales
nicolas sarkozy fera un certain nombre
de déplacements pour soutenir nos
candidats dans les régions et je puis
d'ores et déjà vous annoncer qu'il sera
là mais la semaine prochaine dans l'oise
que le 25 novembre il sera à strasbourg
que le 26 novembre il sera à avignon
le 30 novembre il sera à rouen que le 2
décembre il sera orléans et que le 3
décembre il sera à poitiers il est
encore possible d'ajouter d'autres dates
qui sont à la réflexion est en cours
d'organisation
merci sébastien alors samedi le conseil
national des républicains s'est
rassemblée conseil national dédié aux
élections régionales avec l'ensemble de
nos têtes de liste aux régionales
présentes bruno retailleau marc le fur
virginie calmels riche et yves examen
xavier bertrand valérie pécresse pour
l'île de france christian estrosi avec
des tables rondes dédiées aux régions
une centaine de parlementaires étaient
présents ainsi que 2000 cadres mobiliser
derrière les têtes de liste aux
régionales
notre objectif est d'être mobilisés et
tournée vers la victoire pour les
régionales c'est notre seule priorité
le premier tour puis être en tête
au premier tour donc les républicains
sont mobilisés et unis derrière les
candidats aux régionales allons passer
maintenant aux questions de sécurité
suite à la journée de travail qui a eu
lieu à mardi dernier merci avant de
parler du résultat du vote revenir quand
même sur le contexte le 5 octobre on a
un policier en seine-saint-denis qui a
été tiré comme un lapin et qui sort à
peine du commun par un individu qui
n'aurait jamais dû être dehors
effet induit historique depuis 2001 les
policiers manifestent sous les fenêtres
de la garde des sceaux moyrand signe
apparent constata par tous nos
compatriotes d'une vacance de l'état qui
fait suite aux éléments aux événements
de la a1
vous savez dans la somme où l'autoroute
était devenu la chose d'un groupuscule
d'individus qui demandait que pour une
raison x une personne devait sortir de
prison
en faisant fi de la justice de 2005
l'intérieur de tous les process
république alors même si hier manuel
valls et vous reviendrai dessus je sais
parlait de sa conception de l'autorité
moi je pose la question où est l'état
quand on assiste à ce type de scène
contrairement à ce qu'a dit hier le
premier ministre en particulier pour les
événements de la somme il n'y a pas eu
d'interpellation
il n'y aura donc pas flagrance puisqu'on
a des délais pour qu'il y ait des
flagrants délits donc dans ce contexte
là le 3 novembre nous avons
effectivement réuni une convention
sécurité sur les grandes thématiques
bien sûr constatant le malaise du
service sécurité de coran m'en rendre la
sécurité à nos compatriotes et on a
reposé la question des missions alors on
aurait pu rejouer au ping pong comme la
droite et la gauche aime bien sûr
seulement les effectifs
je pense que si on prend en compte la
crise migratoire
si on prend en compte la menace
terroriste nous allons nous avons
volontairement voulu nous situer sur le
plan des missions
qui pour rendre une meilleure sécurité
demain à nos compatriotes
c est l axe est le deuxième axe est là
aussi ce parce qu'on avait simplement
écouter celles et ceux qui manifestent
dans la rue plus les victimes je suis
mère aussi et les victimes viennent voir
les maires pour leur dire voilà ce que
ce que je subis
c'est donner du sens à l'action de
sécurité donner du sens à l'action de
sécurité c'est rétablir la sanction
rétablir une justice lisible visible par
l'ensemble de nos compatriotes et sortir
du système d'impunité
alors bien évidemment j bien évidemment
parce que pour les lutins ça nous étonne
pas sur les douze questions
toutes ont dépassé les 85 % quel que
soit le domaine qu'il soit très
techniques comme la légitime défense
qu'ils soient pas forcément complètement
consensuel comme l'armement des polices
municipales et aussi sur la musique des
mesures de justice en particulier pour
les mineurs ce qui est très étonnant
c'est la cacophonie gouvernementale
suite à ça je sors pour avoir les dates
exactes sur l'épisode des sociétés
d'autoroutes
on a encore vu samedi ségolène royal
ressortir une grande phrase disant que
cela n'ait pas de rési lisa bhl dans le
cadre d'un état républicain
on parle bien d'un ministre d'un
gouvernement qui fait cette sortie
samedi le 4 novembre remarquer le
ministre de l'intérieur lui-même disait
sur europe 1 qu'il avait déploré les
déclarations belliqueuses de nicolas
sarkozy et qu'il ne voulait pas délégué
ses missions l'un qui sont du domaine
régalien
on parle bien monsieur cazeneuve qui
fait partie du ministère de l'intérieur
de manuel valls
et pourtant le 2 octobre il y avait un
comité interminables à sécurité routière
présidée par le premier ministre ou le
délégué interministériel à la sécurité
routière préconisé cette mesure
donc à un moment donné et du reste
emmanuel barbe c'est le nom du délégué
interministériel à réaffirmer cette
mesure le 5 novembre de ce mois ci donc
à un moment donné vous fait savoir alors
on
peut s'énerver je peux comprendre que
les socialistes s'énerve quand on
constate l'impuissance de l'état
quand on fait le met le doigt là où ça
fait mal mais encore faut-il dire la
vérité au moins s'accorder en interne
c'est un point qui est majeur pour moi
pour montrer aujourd'hui la cacophonie
qui règne dans le gouvernement ce sujet
c'est valable sur un domaine beaucoup
plus technique de la légitime défense en
fonction du ministre interrogé c'est un
peu comme les cdd les réponses sont
différentes sauf que le ministre de
l'intérieur lui-même s'est engagé auprès
des syndicats de policiers avec le
président de la république de revoir les
règles de légitime défense
donc voilà au-delà toute cette polémique
il était nécessaire je pense que nous
fassions en haute voix qu'on donne une
feuille de route
loin des grands projets présidentiels
mais je le répète moyrand la 1 1 le 5
octobre en seine saint denis tous les
jours nos compatriotes constate la
vacance de l'état il était bon qu'on
puisse réaffirmer notre feuille de route
très loin des polémiques on pourrait
reparler de l'eau interpella la petite
polémique on va aujourd'hui aussi sur
les chiffres on a vu que l'indy 500 des
chiffres samedi qu'ils sont mauvais
lohan d'erp et les annoncer et pourtant
le ministre de l'intérieur disait mais
non c'est plus cela qu'il faut prendre
voilà donc on sort nouna cacophonie on
essaie de présenter des mesures claires
et lisibles par l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes et de rester à cela se
traduit par le vote qui a eu lieu
merci merci bruno à l'occasion de
l'intervention de manuel valls dimanche
sur europe 1 a été évoqué le dossier
nissan renault il faut rappeler un
certain nombre de faits en juin dernier
monsieur macron a décidé de jouer au
monopoly avec le titre nissan au nom de
l'état il a racheté massivement des
titres renault pour plusieurs centaines
de millions d'euros
mais le titre renault notamment avec ce
qui s'est passé vis-à-vis de volkswagen
à baisser très fortement alors monsieur
macron s'était fait qu'ouvrir sur ce
risque de baisse de la valeur du titre
renault par la deutsch bank
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que cette
couverture à hauteur de 85% des pertes
possibles se termine au début du mois de
décembre
la volonté de monsieur macron de
racheter east et de racheter ses titres
au mois de juin c'était pour bénéficier
de double vote au sein du conseil
d'administration je passe sur les
détails
la question qui se pose c'est de savoir
ce que va faire monsieur macron va-t-il
vendre les titres renault avec des
pertes très importantes avant le début
du mois de décembre et donc bénéficier
de la couverture à hauteur de 85% mais
il n'en restera pas moins que il y aura
des pertes très importantes à la charge
de l'état et donc à la charge du
contribuable ou va-t-il les conserver et
si les conserves et bien il perdra la
couverture de la deutsche bank et donc
avec un risque que les français payent
plein pot la dévaluation de ce titre
finalement on s'aperçoit que dans cette
histoire le gouvernement monsieur macro
ont joué avec l'argent des français
il se pose aussi un certain nombre de
questions sur le devenir de renault par
rapport à nissan
manuel valls a annoncé qu'il était pour
la poursuite du partenariat le problème
c'est que c'est l'action du de l'état
français en rachetant massivement des
titres qui a posé un problème aux
japonais et qui fait qu'aujourd'hui les
japonais se pose des questions sur
l'avenir de ce partenariat
en parlant éventuellement d'une fusion
donc nous sommes pour le maintien d'un
partenariat à égalité entre
renault et nissan et nous dénonçons ce
jeu et ce monopoly café ce jeu de
monopoly café emmanuel macron avec les
titres renault
alors hier manuel valls était était sur
un média europe 1 et on a pu voir un
premier ministre qui a fait preuve d'une
grande excitation et d'un manque de
maîtrise effectivement les mauvais
résultats qui présente dans tous les
domaines la sécurité
bruno l'a rappelé toutes les
statistiques démontrent que la situation
se dégrade il n'y a qu'une seule courbe
qui baisse c'est celle de la population
carcérale dans le domaine du chômage en
voit qu'ils sont à la peine et qu'une
ministre du travail qui confond cdd cdi
et on peut trouver ça absolument
effroyable quand on connaît la situation
dans laquelle sont les français et la
peine avec laquelle le gouvernement ne
parvient pas à endiguer ce chômage
malgré un traitement social qui est de
plus en plus flagrant une politique de
la famille est désastreuse puisque c'est
la première fois que le taux de natalité
en france diminue et puis une politique
fiscale qu'on ne parvient plus à
comprendre donc tous ces mauvais
résultats font que monsieur valls et
dans une excitation une perte de
maîtrise totale ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'il démontre à quel point elle ne
maîtrise pas ses nerfs et ses seules
réponses sont dans de tomber dans un
espèce de réflexe pavlovien qu'à la
gauche qui est celui de l'anti
sarkozysme
quand ils n'ont rien à proposer en
français quand les français ne veulent
plus les entendre et le gouvernement
le voit à chacun des déplacements on l'a
encore vu à hamoir ans où il s'est fait
siffler eh bien ils tombent sur sur
l'opposition il avait perdu
effectivement l'habitude d'avoir une
opposition mais avec nicolas sarkozy
l'opposition est de retour il va falloir
qu'ils s'y habituent et l'antisarkozysme
primaire ne fonctionne plus aujourd'hui
en france les français ont bien compris
la tactique du gouvernement elle
vaine il va falloir qu'ils en quelque
sorte qui change de disque puisque ça ne
prend plus donc les discours les coups
de menton de monsieur valls c'est bien
beau mais la réalité est totalement
différente l'inaction et la dynaction
est de plus en plus visibles et les
français vont le rappeler je pense très
durement aux socialistes notamment lors
des régionales puis ce qu'on voit que
qui est un effondrement de la gauche il
faut il faut cesser ces vieilles
recettes et que monsieur valls se
rassurent si la fonction le dépasse si
le gouvernement trouve qu'il est trop
difficile de diriger la france 2010
cette approche et l'alternance arrive
très rapidement voilà c'est le message
que nous voulions faire passer à manuel
valls
et puis il y a une véritable psychose
schizophrénique au parti socialiste
entre ceux qui comme monsieur cambadélis
regrette que le front national monte
dangereusement
et puis ceux qui à l'instar de manuel
valls met les républicains et le front
national dans le même sac
c'est à dire en dehors des valeurs de la
république puisque si on écoute bien
manuel valls à l'occasion de cette
émission sur europe 1 et bien pour lui
notre formation politique notre
mouvement est sorti du champ républicain
il y as pour lui plus de différence
entre le front national et les
républicains est ce que c'est en
dévalorisant en fustigeant en
invectivant l'opposition républicaine
le var lutter contre le front national
c'est encore une manoeuvre de la part de
manuel valls comme il le fait très
souvent de en s'érigeant
comme le chantre de l'adversaire du
front national est bien de finalement
envoyé un message subliminal aux
français c'est à dire que son opposition
à lui seul front national non
l'opposition ce sont les républicains et
ce sont les républicains qui sont l'afl
la seule force d'alternance à la
politique qui est menée par le parti
socialiste et à la politique qui est
menée dans chaque région et c'est l
alsace par des représentants du parti
socialiste effectivement c'est toujours
la même dans ce que nous fait un manuel
valls à la veille de scrutin il nous
avait fait la même danse avant les
départementales en faisant tout pour
faire monter le front national
et puis il s'érige en combattant du
front national peut-être pour rassembler
sa gauche mais mais il faut
véritablement rappeler à manuel valls
que le combat contre le front national
semaine toute l'année et semaine par des
politiques publiques qui répondent aux
préoccupations et à la situation des
français sert à rien de se présenter en
rempart du front national quand on fait
tout pour pour le favoriser et pour
qu'ils soient au plus haut dans les
sondages
nous avons reçu une bonne nouvelle ce
matin en provenance de naypyidaw de
l'ancienne capitale de rangoun cdapp
ermani dont il s'agit en effet si on
croit ces échos c'est madame aung san
suu kyi prix nobel de la paix qui aurait
remporté les élections législatives
on salue bien évidemment cette victoire
on remarque un chiffre important 80 % de
participation
c'était un excellent chiffre et si à
l'occasion des élections régionales on
pouvait approcher ce chiffre ça ferait
plaisir à tous les républicains
en tout cas nous notons que c'est une
victoire de la démocratie que la
birmanie sort enfin de la dictature
et puis finalement ça
rend un espoir à tous ceux qui dans le
monde aspirent à la démocratie
tous ceux qui sont sous le joug d'une
dictature et donc les républicains
souhaitent à madame aung san suu kyi
un succès donc pour le futur de la
birmanie